[Music]
it's no secret that esports competitors
can be extremely
regimented in how they play flash for
instance
the greatest competitive gamer to ever
live used to bring a ruler on stage to
ensure that the distance between his
mouse and keyboard was
always the same in fact on the rare
occasion that he lost
adversaries would meme on him for it
hard
parting brings out his own ruler
i love that that is actually one of the
best celebrations i have ever seen oh my
god that's so funny
he can down flash like it was easy
aiming again with his ruler
then there's my boy vinnie who won't
come within a country mile of a
counter-strike server unless he's
donning his
fingerless racing gloves i mean how else
is he gonna go burr
first flashlight second flash is even
better all the third though is the creme
de la creme it's not enough
but this isn't just about some weird
organizational quirks
it's about what they say about those
who've trademarked them
esports are stressful and everyone is
entitled to deal with that stress in
their own way
for some the road to success is paved
with stone cold seriousness
others silliness some get off on smack
talk
whereas others take refuge in song
but there is one top level contestant in
cs go
for whom none of this applies a
sweet soft-faced assailant who's rarely
susceptible to screams
sulks or celebrations of any kind a man
who can't be deemed a winner loser or
anything in between
since ostensibly he's more interested in
vibing
than being victorious who isn't actually
a competitor
as much as he's well a naffer
now give me a big smile a little more
smile
can i get a quick selfie with you sure
man
and now the the winning smile here we go
one versus one final round now for the
awp we talked about the potential
problems with this weapon
on a map like new he's now been taking
down the 62 points of valve another two
verses one can slip by the wayside here
for liquid not the wall bank surely
eight points of help it's zip x is
whittling away
and it will be now flyable wallbang i
can't believe it alex how has he managed
to pull that one off straight through
the wall
now fly today we're talking about keith
nafly markovic the stoic sentinel whose
seemingly sloth-like persona
and playstyle has not only helped
skyrocket his roster to success
but solidify him as one of the most
flexible free-flowing fraggers
cs go has ever
can he find any players down on the
bench yes he can alexi b
caught napping we're gonna bullet
perforating through his head
now this does give liquid a chance they
do have control of the bomb and now
he's found himself a kill next seven
we've got a round of it now ladies and
gentlemen the ball is going to get
planted
and breathing down his neck smoking to
get deployed onto the side to try and
skew direction oh what a flick off to
sergey that is
and i'm not fly gonna use that smoke to
his advantage just pulls back to the van
waiting anticipating an alu push he
comes through the shadows
oh that's ineffable from that fly that's
absolutely sensational
so in what sense did naff's easy
easy-going persona
actually turned him into one of the most
versatile vanquishers
ever how central has his role been to
his roster's
earth-shattering success and what in the
hell
are these chat spamming psychopaths
known
as naffers timing is everything he's
gone
it can't be real didn't see anybody
landing the triple rope to the smoke
i've never seen anything like it
and now at least they're going to get
the bomb plan but faze are being robbed
once again
naf he's still in play in this round on
the other side it's rain and he wants
more
now have you no mercy he's gonna pick up
an
ace in the round an unbelievable
performance
[Music]
all right so in order to understand how
this half asleep head popper
became a secret weapon of sorts we first
need to understand
what made him such a special player to
begin with a product of
source naf was used to fast free-flowing
counter-strike
he kicked off his professional cs go
career in 2014
cutting his teeth on a variety of
scrappy sides
as well 12 seconds remaining player he's
picked up two kills for 10 seconds a
third as well
now fly could clutch his breaks now once
more
all he has to do is play the time first
corner of that line
having cemented himself as one of north
america's most promising talents
naf was given the chance to join optics
brand spank and new cs lineup at the
start of 2016.
and it was there that he really started
to make a name for himself
why well for starters he was insanely
versatile
at the pillar he's got that off and
there's the opening kill what more can
they get
stanislaw falls dexter with two kills
naf's got to do more and he does
the tech knight is out he's wrapping
around the pillar he's going to get
another one four kills he goes for the
aces it's the solo holds from that fly
an incredible performance around that
pillar you see like most esports
counter strike is constituted in such a
way that once you reach a certain level
of competition
you sort of have to pick a position do
you fancy yourself an
opera or a rifler are you more
comfortable being an entry fragger a
lurker
an anchor a support or an igl the thing
that set naf apart was not only his
conversance with pretty much the
entirety of the buy menu
but the comfort with which he shifted
rolls round
to round he does really well plugging
play he
simply fits into most situations and
he's able to adapt to them very
quickly he even though they joke that
he's just lost his thought process is
really fast so
he's able to identify the situation when
he should be up beyond when that that
might change the round
might change something i actually i'm
really confused about why phase slowed
that down so much
because they just got the first two
kills flawlessly and there's
one person left on the bomb side why
don't you just run him over as well why
not run him down
[Music]
i'm more in awe of naf and this
ridiculous round playing it perfectly
but the other thing that caught people's
attention was his overall
let's say calmness
naf was basically the epitome of your
so-called
classic gamer an easy-going seemingly
uninvested
badass who carries himself with the
utmost
confidence while casually owning scrubs
the difference is that those scrubs were
more often than not
the best players the game had ever seen
kirby could have maybe even got the
double kill now that flies down here
the hero of optic gaming he goes for the
spray catches dupree
perfectly follows up with a headshot on
sipnix
this guy in the grand finals 34 kills
now
he just needs another couple and they
will have that trophy
it's going to be caribbean glaive left
with over a minute but in a two on four
spray comes through rice gets a kill and
ladies and gentlemen optic gaming
you're winners of e-league season two
you've heard of the expression
cool as a cucumber naf might as well
have been an
ice cube this dude wasn't just chill
he was barely present sometimes it
looked like he had no idea where he was
other times like he just didn't care
except as his opponents will
surely attest nothing could have been
further from the truth
he has to run in and actually try and
get the job done
well they're playing a bit of a game
with him right now i think
scream just up and down the ladder and
nap he realizes he's got the double kill
looking for a bit of a spray there but
they're just buying so much time good
shot for naff and he's coming a bit
alive in some of these rounds if he had
any grenades it might be possible
but scream is down there oh sorry this
is up there and it's gonna be the
molotov reigning in and that's just
gonna
seal the round here gonna be the kill
but he has no time to get him to get
this defuse that's the stand of the fire
and there's not going to be time i think
oh
oh wow wow last possible second
a little bit of a cheesy smile in fact
on naf i like that one
the issue with being that unstructured
of a player of course
is that well you kind of need structure
around you if you're going to be
to quote naf's namesake nutty is
if the roster on which our boy found
himself wasn't regimented enough or he
was pigeonholed into a particular role
he wouldn't play to his full potential
so i think keith knapp's problem isn't
with structure
it's one structure isn't done correctly
right because
he knows how it's supposed to be done so
if you get someone in his spot doing
something
that he knows how to do better it
creates a frustration
going there like show your [ __ ] mouth
[Laughter]
this is so stupid like we know what
they're doing like where they're going
please show okay just don't talk to me
this
and apparently as laid back as he was if
that
infrastructure wasn't there
dude could get a little tilted there was
one game naf tried calling i remember on
like cash like a long time
like calling calling right yeah and like
certain people like didn't listen to him
one round and i was like
by the end of 2017 naff's docile
dumpster fests
had really started to catch the
attention of the community
after optic was poached to the point of
implosion naf spent the next three
months
wrecking fools on renegades before being
tapped to play for one of his
region's biggest orgs liquid
i remember when he was joining team
liquid and he's just like it was
super casual slap me into any situation
and i'll fit in
and it isn't always like that but the
fact that he sees himself as like that i
think is amazing
uh i don't know when i usually come into
teams i just like do my own thing
like they don't like i don't know it's
just like i just they just plug me and i
can just plug in and out of teams pretty
well
but yeah i don't know i think just
adding me was just like there's just
more
more we can do like i can rifle like an
op i can do a lot of things i can lurk i
can go in first
so i think just bringing me and i just i
just bring a lot to the team
and it was there whilst donning the blue
and white
that everything would eventually click
do they want to wait for it
now they're finally gonna put it out and
try and push their way through oh and
it's two for one
then third one nap absolute rock solid
defense
shutting down four players they had
absolutely no chance to make it through
and it actually costs him in the end
because they boost up above so
oh naf oh that is unreal
two preemptive shots and the edge the
both goes back and finds them further as
they try and jump down on top of water
he didn't know he had access to it rpk
as a result gets two but that was
inevitable
unfortunately for enough he's left alone
and they know exactly where he is at
this point in time so balm
will stay where it is half with the only
smoke he could throw has to get by even
trying to use
the particles he got the information he
finds
the shot instead with nitro calling the
shots
stewie causing chaos twists making sure
his hair
and head shots were on point and elige
cementing himself as the spray pattern
whisperer
naf was finally given the freedom to do
what he wanted
when he wanted to play as intuitively as
he pleased
gonna try and pull off a miracle but
these angles are just so far away and
he's got nothing to use and you might as
well just stick it i guess and actually
oh my god he might just do it a mistake
from astralis
oh and a miraculous headshot to follow
it was his only option
by about midway through 2019 liquid had
solidified themselves as both the best
cs go roster in the world
and the greatest north american ensemble
ever
tournament after tournament they clapped
the competition
thanks in part to naf's proclivity
towards absent-minded ownage
god himself in the cathedral to try and
shut down naf
incendiary on the box oh my goodness
creeping up so close snap out and you
can change that horse symbol to a moose
because that fly
has got number 11 for liquid in fact
it was around this time that a meme
began to take shape
one that parodied both naf's physical
appearance
and stoner meets a space cadet manner of
carrying himself
by comparing him to well a sloth
nasty as daft is a grand slam champion
and one of the greatest north american
players encounter
strike history but fly is known for
sleeping several times in a day
while also destroying noobs in the
silver in the same day
they can swim pretty fast apparently my
people swim fast
so he was a guy that when we were having
team discussions he'd just be sometimes
looking around doing anything
kind of in sloth mode actually and then
we talked to me like i'm weird like that
guys don't worry about it
and when he's having a moment on stage
or something like that he'd be super
chilly like guys don't just don't worry
about me i'm gonna do my thing so he's
super on his own
yet at the same time he's doing
everything
and their win loss at that point will be
high enough so they shouldn't have any
dramas
two with the usps that's a third
this suddenly becomes more than winnable
this becomes problematic
some needs to hope and pray that elijah
overstays
his welcoming has crossed over but nap
could still get some more here he's on
for an ace with the usp
opts for a fresh one to finish off the
job bender
what's the dunk laura and i'm calling
him hey yeah the nade's there back to
the way he's got himself an ak
[Music]
kills thus a special
subsection of counter-strike fan came to
be
a legion of adoring spammers who hung
out in chat
not to cheer for liquid or their
opponent but for naf in particular
as such they could never be classified
as winners
or losers but disciples who'd
affectionately termed themselves
naffers damn it feels good to be another
any others in chat
[Music]
dude naf just he always looks so laid
back he's like the sloth i swear
that was like the just the limpest
bump hope there are some nephes in the
chat now to be clear
naf is capable of showing emotion it
just takes something genuinely
extraordinary to awake him from his
sweet sloth-like stupor hey
why do you never smile smile smile
sharks falling back into the bomb side
do they really want to chase him
he seems to be in a position he's taking
him down
why are we still here
just to suffer the reality of course is
that naf's seemingly
brain-dead brilliance isn't just a meme
it's a testament to the fact
that as useful as discipline is not
everyone excels under strict regimes
there are certain savants who just can't
flourish unless they're given
free reign geniuses for whom
prescription
is death and naff is one of them
christie plucks twists off of the
balcony naf now realizes the error of
his ways
but maybe he can recover this on his own
he drops the bomb carrier who is looking
oh
looking to join them and well naf will
let robs join his two dead teammates
holy hell of a no scope and chris j now
we're going to get a little bit of
combat opping two snipers
in the apps chris flicks hits the shot
but nafla
takes the kill since joining liquid
naff's masterful meandering has earned
him the distinction of being ranked
among the top 10 players on the planet
for two years straight he may look and
play like some notoriously sleepy
wildlife
but there's no question that he's world
class
and this is the only way you get one
sorry
tess says
he rifles he ups he does a lot of
clutches he has those insane moments
and he has the funny reactions where
he's just upset at something so he has
the highest he has the lows
but he is an insanely talented player
and while liquid have been struggling
since their reign of terror was in full
swing
part of the reason for their decline was
that certain roster maneuvers had
forced naf to adopt a more rigid and
fixed playstyle
but since fallen joined the team it's
already looking like
naf is getting back to his best nat
falling back that's a
pretty decent kill can we get a
follow-up no he's gonna have to reload
and that might buy oh what naff coming
through with a big
triple and it's so unbelievable and
he'll finish it off with a quad kill
actually an
ace at the end he took every single one
he's able to be the x factor when he
if he knows everything that's going on
he can fit in if he thinks he knows and
then it isn't going then it gets crazy
that isn't about structure
sometimes just about that structured
chaos i guess you could say it's not the
perfect thing it's just
there has to be an understanding here it
has to be flow that chemistry and i
think they have it now
even if liquid never again reached such
unprecedented heights
one thing is for sure watching naf let
loose in
and out of the server has taught the
counter-strike community
a ton about the importance of
self-expression
about playing the game your way
bang bang one dead two dead buster
killed me actually and that is why
whatever happens win or lose it'll
always
feel damn good to be a naffer
but it is still 3v3 everybody's in the
same position
oh my god what he just runs right
through
and team legend stop come on man what
the hell
flash flash for instance the great
i just can't speak today to ever live
used to bring a
of course but this isn't about just but
this isn't just
holy [ __ ] okay but there's one top level
compel
you see counter see today we're talking
about keith
keith jesus it's like that dog with the
teeth
keef